so after the incredible positive
response i received from my last video
comparing
archicad 23 against revit
i thought it was time to take an
in-depth look into archicad 24
and the new heavyweight in the game
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich welcome back to the channel
archicad 24 was just announced in
australia
and it has some incredible features that
i want to talk to you about today
if you didn't see my last video
comparing archicad to revit and that's
something you're interested in
make sure you go back and check that out
first because today we're going to be
talking about archicad as a standalone
powerhouse platform so if you're already
an archicad 23 user and looking to
upgrade
wondering what's different and want to
know straight away
well the answer is pretty simple
graphisoft is really focusing on the bim
integration
for archicad 24. they're putting a lot
of their key focus and key ideas
into structural modeling structural
analysis and mep design
if you don't know what mep design stands
for it stands for mechanical
electrical and plumbing so one of the
main upgrades to archicad 24 is the
integration and upgrade of the bimcloud
many of us have used the bimcloud or a
variation of the bimcloud
in the past which allows us to basically
connect to our team members
outside of the office at home
potentially or overseas
with covert 19 being such a huge issue
in the global economy as it stands today
in 2020
introducing the bimcloud and upgrading
its features
seems like a very smart decision on
graphisoft's behalf
if you're a regular to the channel
welcome to the first ever scene change
i think that truly deserves a like and
subscribe if
the video so far hasn't convinced you so
in this corner of the house we're going
to be talking a little bit more about
the bimcloud and what the bimcloud
can do as a standalone service online
so archicad is focused predominantly on
the fact that the bimcloud
can now be accessed by anybody from
anywhere in the world
this means if you have access to the
internet and a https secured connection
then you can access the bimcloud and
access all the data that you previously
had to have locally on a onedrive or
any other external server so what is the
bimcloud the bimcloud is now
a standalone feature that allows
everybody to collaborate in the one
space so if you have a team of
structural engineers
civil engineers and maybe some
mechanical guys a construction team
and the client themselves you can
integrate this all into the bimcloud
and then allow separate sections for
uploading different styles of
documentation
constantly being informed about what is
being managed what is being transitioned
and all the new information being
presented on the software another key
element here
is the simple fact of having the ability
to either roll back
or check previous documentation so if
you as the architect
or you as a structural engineer have
gone and uploaded a set of drawings
to the bimcloud but realized that you've
made potentially a fatal error
on the latest revision you can double
check how far back that error goes
and make sure that everybody in the team
is informed of this information
asap now obviously this is a dramatic
example and it could be something as
simple as just wanting
to go back and check something on a
previous example that somebody's
potentially pointed out that you may
have
missed or added in the next set of
drawings but it is a good feature that
we're all now accustomed to
on features like onedrive and google
drive with the ability of
rollbacks so starting with some simple
changes in the bimcloud
first of all it is again focused on the
structural and the mep integration
really trying to combine all the
engineers and all the architects
together
as i'm sure many of us are aware this is
a huge challenge
when designing and working on a very
large scale project
however with the bimcloud model compare
is a new feature that allows you
to simply understand and track changes
that have been made
by people other than yourself or
yourself included
so basic quick summary is allowing you
to track
changes if somebody in team b overseas
or at home goes and makes a few changes
uploads it to the cloud and sends their
project data across
you can quickly and automatically view
the differences between that model and
your model
now this is a very handy feature if you
have new staff members
or are struggling to communicate large
amounts of information across the board
it gives you a graphical representation
of what's changed
what's remained and what elements you
need to focus on and worry about
so if some beam sizes or some column
sizes have gotten significantly bigger
you can quickly and easily implement
this into your updated model
now an added benefit is that you can
produce
notes in these changes so if somebody
sends you a change that you don't like
or isn't perfect
you can quickly select those elements
that you want them
to adjust and change take a screenshot
include it in the
issues notes section and then type a
quick little note to that person
saying column two short column two small
increase balustrade height or whatever
the issue might be
this is a really really handy feature if
you're
doing a project that has thousands and
thousands of changes
or is rather complex trying to manage a
team on a bim project can be a huge
headache
so being able to create an issues list
which becomes more or less a to-do list
later down
the project is very handy and a good
reminder
for anything that you may have missed by
just shouting at people and telling them
to change this change that one thing
that is the catch here with the bimcloud
service
is it is a paid subscription with covert
19 happening now in 2020
it is a little bit cheaper to access
bimcloud
and to subscribe to a one-year
membership than it is regularly
but i know that feature expires on the
31st of august here in australia
now data and privacy go hand in hand in
2020.
we know companies like facebook have
previously gone under the hammer for
breaches of data and privacy
so being able to control your data in a
secure manner is very important on the
bimcloud
it gives you the full access to truly
manage
individual teams and grant access based
on their requirements
if you've been using archicad for a
while now you've probably well aware of
the fact that their furniture
and objects are pretty poor most of us
have to download
external libraries or constantly add to
our libraries
in some way shape or form you'll be
happy to know that archicad 24 is
releasing
40 on a huge number but 40
brand new residential objects this
varies anywhere
from beds sofas wardrobes and lamps and
accessories
so if you've been looking for something
a bit more modern in your 3d renders
this could be a good upgrade for those
brand new objects
so an experimental feature that has been
added into archicad 24
that is also being promoted as a very
large feature in itself
is the addition of python scripts if you
don't know what python scripts are
basically it allows you to do parametric
design inside
archicad and lets you integrate your
software with
rhino and grasshopper another new
feature has come to mac
only so if you're an apple user this
one's for you
archicad 24 has now introduced a dark
mode
in to archicad 24 so like the new ios
update that allows you to put your whole
screen into dark mode
and save your eyes from those blinding
white lights all day long
you can now finally transition archicad
into
dark mode now if you ask me this is
really going back to the days of autocad
and the 2d line drawings on that black
screen
i don't know how much i'm going to like
it i love dark mode everything of mine
is in dark mode so it's definitely going
to be an interesting feature that i
can't wait to try out
right so this is scene change number two
in this video
which means i'm truly making a real
active effort
to make sure to produce some high
quality content for you guys
i've never recorded down here in the
stairwell
so the acoustics might be absolutely
terrible and i may never record here
again
but the simple active effort i believe
requires a like and subscribe further to
my point that archicad 24
is really trying to become an integrated
platform between structural engineers
and architects
the integrated platform is now becoming
more and more
user-friendly for engineers to jump on
board and start documenting
inside archicad so like you can on revit
now archicad
truly provides an inbuilt structural
analysis software
where you can understand your loads your
load-bearing capacity
and the connection point between columns
beams slabs and roofs
if this is something that a structural
engineer in your team knows about
i would truly recommend that this is a
structural engineer's domain
and that architects drafts people
designers don't take on
this mission of a software update there
are so many features
that we aren't really familiar with as
architects and designers
so it's an important fact that these
structural engineers become
part of your team get on board with
archicad and start using
the absolute maximum capabilities that
are now available in archicad 24.
for example one of these upgrades is a
bi-directional archicad model export
you can take your archicad bim model
export the structural information
into what they call a sam model or a
structural
analytical model that allows engineers
to import this data
directly into their engineering software
so for example
there's a saf file that exports all your
data all your structural data
as an excel document and pumps it out to
the engineers these guys can now
import this excel data and don't ask me
how excel can transform into a full
3d model in their structural analysis
programs once they're finished making
modifications to the structural
elements of the design they can send you
a modified
excel or saf file back and then you can
directly import that into archicad 24
again automatically updating it to a 3d
elements and components and see the
changes that have been made
so going back to my previous comments on
tracking changes and understanding
changes of different team members
the bimcloud now allows you to integrate
these engineers
directly with your model now this is an
extremely complicated procedure and i
would recommend it only on
very complex projects if you're doing
something as simple as a warehouse or a
shed and it has no
real architectural or structural
significance to it
then it's probably easier to continue
doing it the way you're doing it now
however if you're doing a very large
scale project
with hundreds of thousands of different
structural members that you have to
cross
every single time there's an update well
then this is definitely something
worth investigating and trying out it is
going to be something that your senior
designer or your senior architect takes
on board
as a challenge because understanding bim
and bim modeling in a whole sense
is a full-time job it is something that
somebody has to monitor
review and check continuously to make
sure
no mistakes or no key flaws have been
brought up between the consultants
understanding this one model and working
as one team
now archicad 24 hasn't forgotten about
the mechanical guys
the hvac plug-in is completely
integrated into archicad 24 this time
around
so unlike revit you don't have to go and
purchase another plug-in
you can have all this information ready
at your fingertips
this might mean that some engineers
might be a bit more convinced to move
over to the archicad platform
versus the revit platform now knowing
the fact that a
archicad is cheaper than revit and b the
mep plugin is
directly inbuilt into the software so
now using an engineer that's already in
archicad
doing all their plumbing mechanical and
electrical in archicad is going to make
this
significantly quicker and significantly
easier
for you and us to understand the model
and the whole project as a whole
the bimx app has also had a significant
update
to really let your clients explore their
model and explore their project
i think personally for me the one key
standout feature
is the increased performance of
photorealistic rendering
which now includes real-time light
rendering this is meant to be done on
any device across any platform
be it a ipad an iphone or your web
browser
entirely in its own standalone platform
it should be able to handle
this real time light tracing which is
definitely a huge leap forward for an
app of this caliber
anyway that's all from me today guys i
hope you enjoyed the video
to summarize archicad 24 i believe it is
really focused on bim and the
integration of your structural and civil
engineers together with the architects
i think if you're going to be using the
bimcloud system
you're going to want a senior designer
or a senior architect on this project
full time
to really try and manage the bim model
itself
that is going to be a full-time job in
itself
so make sure you take a look at the
software look at it in depth before
jumping onto it on a very large project
and making many mistakes
but in general i think it is moving
towards more of a powerhouse platform
that can compete with revit now on its
own basis
anyway thanks so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button 2020 style and as always
i'll see you next monday